The next question we had was about internationalization and localization.
A lot of our students are all across the world. How do we support something on that scale?
It's actually not that hard. The hardest part is doing the translation.
There's a package you can use called gettext,
and this is built into Python in most major languages.
Basically what you do is in your templates, you either put all of your strings in one place,
in one module, and in your templates, and in that module you--
I think in Python, the function that we use looks like an underscore,
and you just put all your strings inside this underscore function.
Then you just have a separate file that's a database of all of the--for in our case,
English language strings to whatever language and then your website just kind of works.
Well, you'll basically say, "Here's the language I want to use,
and here is where I store all my translation files."
And then everything will just kind of translate on its own.
Basically, Google for gettext Python,
and you will see a whole bunch of information.
And we'll include some links on that in the office hours instructor comments
just to help you guys out. >>Great. Great. That's why he's here.